the level of recognition from the time
that you started on the show say until
now you've seen it obviously just in
your personal life increase when you
when you go anywhere you get this kind
of reaction that wouldn't have happened
the number of years ago to the same
intensity what's it like for you getting
used to it um I've learned to navigate
it better lately but you know earlier on
I didn't really know what was happening
I think the worst thing that ever
happened to me was the colonoscopy
incident that's the most chilling
sentence I've heard in a long time I
think the colonoscopy incident yeah all
right it was a favorite fish I know it's
for hours yeah I you know I am yeah I
needed a colonoscopy and it was early on
maybe like to get a check-up yeah yeah
yeah my brother had some things and he
was totally fine but they're like you
should get checked out to it so I got
checked out I'm sitting with the doctor
and the doctor has great bedside manner
I'm in my gown and he goes so you know
you're kind of young for doing this but
you'll be all right what do you do
trying to calm me down and I say oh I'm
an entertainment he's like you're an
actor I'm like yes and he goes what show
are you on I say oh I'm on the show
called The Walking Dead and he's like
I've heard of it
but I I don't watch it and I was like
okay cool it's gonna go great yeah so
they start to put the IV in and they
cart me into the room where they're
gonna do the procedure in IV is that so
it sort of starts to put you to sleep I
going to sleep and then he tells me to
turn on my side like this and then
there's a tech behind me who has not
seen me yet and he just goes you're
gonna feel something cold and I felt
something cold
yeah right
and then the doctor sees that I'm kind
of like you know like uncomfortable with
what's happening and he's like hey it's
all good
what does that show that you said you're
on again and then I go the walking dead
and the tech behind me goes oh walkie
dead
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I could feel the moment of recognition
internal yeah intern yeah did he say if
I'd known I would have warmed it up for
ya so yeah and then and then the problem
is you're probably seconds away from oh
then then I was like yeah it's me better
than anyone
yeah all right let's that is truly a
horrifying story let's get Craig much
more a Steven Yeun in a second stick
around
you